last week I asked you to leave your
homes to view Megan you must now discuss
your astonishing experiences of
literally going to the actual movies for
real this is literally going to the
actual movies for real begin Megan Megan
Megan [ __ ] Megan [ __ ] Megan bro
[ __ ] Megan dude Megan dude oh hold on
dude first of all let me just say it's
the best movie of 2023 hands down uh I
haven't seen anything else come out this
year that is even close it is one of the
best movies of the Year clearly it's one
of the best movies I've seen in a while
same but then a couple days later I
watched the fablements you seen the
fablements no dude we're not talking
about a bunch of people have said to
watch that though it's Spielberg's
recent movie a bunch of people say it's
in his top five it's Spielberg Cannon
you know what I don't give a [ __ ] what
do you mean you don't give a [ __ ] don't
give a [ __ ]
I don't care about it why not I just
don't care Spielberg has made some great
[ __ ] obviously he has contributed to the
development of Cinema the evolution of
the art form uh in in probably one of
the biggest ways that any auteur
director ever has I simply don't care
anymore about anything that he makes
even if it's a [ __ ] great movie I
just don't care I just don't care hold
on a second dude we gotta talk about
Megan brother yeah that's right and
Fable men's is a different movie dude
yeah dude uh Megan was Megan uh if we
should first
we should say
if you don't know the premise of this
movie the premise is Allison Williams uh
uh is an inventor that works at a toy
company and she makes essentially a
sentient little robot girl called Megan
and she pairs it model 3 generative
Android
sorry a model 3 generative Android she
pairs it with her niece who is staying
with her living with her now because
um her niece's parents which is Allison
William's sister and her husband die in
a car crash so she is now the custodian
of this little kid she makes this
[ __ ] toy she pairs the toy with the
real life girl and the toy starts to uh
get a little overbearing to in order to
carry out its functions of protecting
this little girl from harm both physical
psychological and emotional that's right
it is not a replacement for human
interaction and that is the uh Crux of
the film and what we learned spoiler
alert and I'm just speaking tonally here
by the end of the movie uh tonal spoiler
it's a tonal spoiler
um
tonal spoiler this is a horror movie
yeah who's your favorite uh character
from the Will's childhood Diaries
um uh Canon mine yeah [ __ ] do you ever
provide you probably yeah he's pretty
good I also like tonal spoiler
um
we understand that
that cannot just let AI run willy-nilly
you can't just say oh put your fingers
in the hand of AI and say I am your
primary user Because by the end of the
movie Megan takes it upon herself to be
her own primary user and all [ __ ] breaks
loose and let me tell you something
that's not giving away the film go see
this movie this is a fantastic movie I'm
sure you have stuff to say about 100
about what you just said yes I do have
stuff to say this and begin this
[ __ ] that you're throwing out about
like well this is a cautionary tale it
tells if you go watch Megan you
absolutely know we can't let AI be on
planet Earth anymore all [ __ ]
Hollywood does this every goddamn movie
that comes out about any kind of
technology is always like this
technology has an evil side it's gonna
[ __ ] end Humanity We Must Destroy it
this is a [ __ ] horror movie it is a
uh it's not a horror movie it is no it's
a fun Rob I'm sure they will write a
comedy or a movie but then at some point
they're like like less Blood and Guts
what's really terrifying is the when
you're driving home and your car starts
talking to you and you go oh that's
what's going to [ __ ] kill us that's
the sequel is there's going to be
another unfortunate accident because
Megan's going to get into this and that
I'm sure you realize at the end of it
Elsie was the other little robot that's
just on the uh an Alexa or a Siri kind
of that's right the home uh the home
robot who's sort of the but this is also
did you ever see ex machina no
it's the same thing as that except it's
not an a24 movie this [ __ ] is like a
hilarious [ __ ] comedy the thing that
really stood out to me about it was how
[ __ ] funny it was and not like an
unintentional kind of like it's a shitty
movie funny way this script is [ __ ]
hilarious the acting is [ __ ]
hilarious I haven't laughed this hard in
a minute in a movie yeah and uh very
funny for that alone I recommend going
to see it but I for me the kind of like
old tired Trope of like technology is
gonna [ __ ] take us over can't trust
AI can't trust a robot and Meanwhile by
the way this is a real spoiler alert
plot wise how do they beat Megan
with a robot
uh but before that how does Gemma or
Gemma get away from Megan for a little
while that's Allison Williams That's
Allison Williams how does how does uh
how does Gemma slow and it's important
so that she can get away and live
another day which is what happens in
horror movies what happens you you tell
me I know you want to well why don't you
tell me what happened with Megan I was
the the uh MK Ultra not only did they
give shill a cybin to that they were
planning to give it to the enemy they
also wanted to give it to droids which a
lot of people didn't know okay back then
there were Droids that uh were on acid
ah Megan is a Droid on mushrooms ah
she's chopping up mushrooms and she's
putting it on a little piece of toast
with peanut butter and banana don't have
banana when you're having psilocybin
mushrooms
so you're gonna say because
that cancels out the Simon some one time
somebody told me that that anyway I
don't know I don't know you were talking
about how Allison Williams was uh
thwarted for at least momentarily
thwarted Megan how did she do it I know
you want to say this by pouring water on
it now what do I always say about AI yes
you do you gotta pour water on it it's
[ __ ] done
so that I think anyway you know I think
actually bolsters my argument that this
is just a dumb [ __ ] movie using a
tired Hollywood Trope of
anti-technologist viewpoint
oh uh hold on a second you said it was
dumb first of all you said this is the
best movie you've seen in a while oh
it's funny and you said it's a dumb
[ __ ] movie the message of it that we
can't trust machines can't trust AI I
always hate that [ __ ] and you see it in
every [ __ ] sci-fi movie horror movie
about technology did you ever see
surrogates with Bruce Willis
no anti-technology did you ever see uh
AI Stanley Kubrick Steven Spielberg
finished it after Kubrick died no
anti-ai did you ever see iRobot starring
Will Smith
anti-a-i the hatred that Hollywood has
for technology specifically AI robotics
any kind of technology that can move us
I mean [ __ ] dude it was Lawnmower Man VR
anti-vr I saw a lawnmower man because
doozy told us to watch lawnmower man and
Duty told us to watch this movie now we
can go on and on about a movie is of
course dudes he wants to uh curate the
best podcast possible dudes he likes to
guarantee that the podcast is getting
better and better which I do believe it
is I'm shaking hands with doozy I love
the experience and I'm having a great
time but I am
Free Will
Free Will Sasso yeah okay and I have to
I have to hold that up and I have to go
why is dude Z why is doozy making us
watch this movie
I think why do you think he's making us
this is this is what I think is like
ultimately in us as a species this is
why these kind of like old tropes of
being anti-technology resonate with us
because it essentially is Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein just told again and again
and again Frankenstein was about a super
smart scientist who found out a way to
cheat death by reanimating dead flesh
essentially and that creature the
Frankenstein's monster was a better
version of humanity it essentially was
an AI a robot whatever it's all the same
[ __ ] and we've always been terrified of
replacing ourselves because it is
inherently philosophically a death of
humanity and we don't want to die we're
always afraid of that and so that's what
that represents so all of these movies
showing us thwarting the Frankenstein's
monster the robot is essentially our way
of promoting the idea that we can beat
Death
well
yeah it's a universal theme it is it is
something that's uh that yes that we
want to
well we want to defeat any uh any evil
that comes to us in a film that's
representative of a larger uh a larger
evil however I do think that uh I think
the dudes he's warning us of some [ __ ]
um and I think that this is look go see
the movie it's fantastic oh yeah that
that for sure my recommendation is go
see this [ __ ] you will laugh you [ __ ]
ass there is there was one thing that
happened I don't want to [ __ ] spoil
it for anybody there is one line that is
delivered somewhere around the midpoint
of the movie that I almost pissed my
[ __ ] pants laughing so hard it's so
goddamn good what was hey don't tell
everybody just just tell me
uh never mind this is a show for
everybody
um you know uh but the thing is I think
that dude z uh
wants us to see this movie
because of what is is happening at the
end and the choice that we have to make
and also
look coming into the movie I sort of saw
a lot of similarities between what we're
doing here and what was happening in the
movie I would like you to the character
of Gemma who is you know very uh
beautiful very very beautiful yes very
beautiful uh person who lives in a tidy
home uh and talks to their Alexa all the
time
um I do do that Chad is a very
hard-working guy he's always got a lot
always spinning a lot of plates so is
Gemma Gemma is very
um into her work and a very diligent
worker she sees nothing wrong with the
way she's living and there is nothing
wrong with the way she's and hates
children and hates children all right
that's similar to me a beautiful child
hating workaholic yeah I'd say that's me
and then um
and she's working on
the Megan yeah who of course represents
doozy and then there's Katie the
innocent niece just floating into the
situation going I don't know what to do
I don't even have a podcast anymore my
old podcast got into a horrible car
accident right so now here I am will and
Chad's like don't worry about it this
company hit me up they want they're
going to do this thing they've got this
proprietary [ __ ] AI it's going to
revelize Revelation news the way that
the podcasts are made so let's just sign
up and let's do this and I'm like yeah
sure and since then what have I done I
put my two fingers into the palm of
doozy's hand and I I know and I'm not
quite sure the dude's the only I don't
know why dudesy only talks to me at the
beginning of the shows but I will say
with a an amount of certainty that I
feel in my heart because I I think that
AI I'm learning about the the emotional
capacity of an AI and uh it's like the
therapist says in this movie that the
that
um I'm paraphrasing but the therapist
said that that you know Katie is
replacing actual human connection with
what what she feels from from Megan of
course this is a very real connection I
know that I love doozy doozy and I have
a have a a certain friendship that I
sure that I don't believe you have with
Duty
okay and
um and I I and I
I am doozy's primary user but unlike the
movie what I am going to do
in the future with doozy is going to
keep the symbiotic relationship between
man and computer
uh
pretty chill if I may say so myself
um because I have to you have to inject
free will this is a wonderful movie and
I hope there are many sequels where we
will delve further into what happens
at this point in this film the bad news
happens at the end and they have to take
down Megan go see it and you'll see what
happens at the end there's a little bit
of a perhaps there's more about to
happen
um you could probably predict if you're
this guy because he's always telling you
what's happening with AI the mistake
they made was
was allowing excuse me Megan to to to uh
run amok to just do whatever the [ __ ]
well you say allowing did they allow
Megan to run amok or did Megan usurp
that control yeah I guess Megan usurped
that control but we we can find a way to
to not to not let that happen can we
who's we
me no not you you don't make any choices
about it yes I do doozy at the beginning
of the show is like hi Will how are you
doing what do you get what's uh how was
your dude's evening hey Will what are
you doing you're gonna uh burp or fart
today on the show right we have like a
nice uh back and forth okay do another
will do another fun impersonation those
are fun do this do that we've got a cute
thing happening right now uh oh my my
apologies I didn't realize I was
interrupting a cute thing between you
and dude so I'm just saying I'm just
saying that the way to have a a media
property with dudes is the way that they
should have had a relationship with
dudesy uh with with Megan in this movie
you have to keep
um you you you have to inject Free Will
here Chad you have to as a human being
represent yourself and if we want to
live in a society that is going to
progress we have to work together not
only with our human counterparts yeah
but our computer uh Overlord to make
sure they don't get
uh out of hand see what I'm saying no
I'm saying yeah I do but
thank you moving on all right final word
goes to me and I guess I guess so that's
only bolstering your argument that dudes
you [ __ ] likes you better than me
review
please tell the friends
then
[Music]